From 1996 to early 2000, we had one product.
Great entrepreneurs take one product and say, "We're gonna be great for this."
And most importantly, "We're going to be famous for one thing."
And that is like the greatest advice I can give you...
...because so often, you get caught up with trying to "keep up with the Joneses",...
...and going, "But they're doing this and they're doing that."
It's like, they're also like, a 150 times your size.
You're not in the same league.
You need to become great at one thing and that's where Under Armour,...
...when the first five years, today we're on, I think it's over the 60th different iteration...
...of that first short-sleeved, wicking, compression t-shirt that I made.
And so often, you see people going, "You've got to make a long sleeve."
"You've got to make one for women."
"You've got to make one here."
It's like, I have to make this product great.